supervisors report I would like to  formally excuse myself to all our  customers authorities and nothing we  would I would like to ask you kindly to  give false VAR another chance and in  order to regain your trust and ladies  and gentlemen I want to also underline  that this should not continue and the  case until the case is the clarified  certain employees will be suspended and  the coordination and the super security  for the observation of the following  consequences will be also put into  action and the American prosecutors will  also take further steps and progressive  consequences through supervisory board  will cake recording measures as well  listen gentlemen the board and concern  of a Volkswagen really do our best to  step by seven regain the lost trust